Hello, everyone. It's Dr.
Carl Abraham doing this
lecture on a skin and
mucous membrane infections.
Our session objectives
are to describe
the roles of
microbiome virulence
factors and host
defense mechanisms.
play in prevention of or
development of skin and
mucous membrane infections
and to describe common
medically important
pathogens that cause skin
and mucous membrane
infection as well as diagnose
these pathogens that
cause these infections.
I've included a QR
code with a link to the
ScholarRx brick on bacterial
infections of the skin.
As you all know,
we are completely
covered in bacteria. This
is the normal flora
of the skin. The same
is true for the mucous
membranes beginning
with the oropharynx and
ending with the ****.
The normal flora of the skin
is predominantly gram positive.
Almost 30 to 60 percent
of the population has
Staphylococcus aureus
as a skin colonizer. 30
percent of those, or
about half of those, are
permanently colonized with
Staphylococcus aureus.
About 30 percent or
half of those are
transiently colonized
from time to time.
Everyone, though, is
colonized with another
Staphylococcus, Staphylococcus
epidermidis. Many people
are colonized in mucous
membranes, especially
the oropharynx with
Streptococcus pyogenus. That's
also called group A
streptococcus or GAS for
short, and other skin
colonizers include the
diphtheroids carotibacterium
and propionibacterium.
Gram-negative organisms
normally do not colonize
the skin of the upper torso
and face, but but they
can transiently colonize
moist areas such as the
axillae gram negatives are
more predominant around
the waist and in those with
chronic illness especially
diabetes there is increased
prevalence of gram
negative organisms in the
lower extremities fungi
that colonize the mucous
membranes include candida
albicans, and on the skin,
various dermatophytes.
The staphylococci are the
main colonizers of the skin.
These are gram-positive,
catalase-positive,
non-motile cocci from
0.5 to 1.5 micrometers
in diameter. They grow
well on blood agar in
high salt concentration
and at a range of
temperatures, but they
do not grow on McConkie
agar catalase is an
enzyme that staphylococci
produce that decomposes
a hydrogen peroxide
into water and oxygen
we'll show that
that's a virulence
factor on the next slide
it's a staphylococci or
facultative anaerobes
and they may be
sensitive or resistant
to methicillin, which
directs us which
antibiotics we can use
for treatment. First
species of staphylococci
we'll talk about is
Staphylococcus aureus. This
is a very important pathogen,
as opposed to other
staphylococci, which are all
catalase positive, including
Staphylococcus aureus.
Staphylococcus aureus
is coagulase positive.
Other staphylococci
are coagulase negative.
Staphylococcus aureus is also
beta hemolytic on blood agar.
Key virulence factors
that the bacteria produce
include the coagulase,
which converts
fibrinogen to fibrin, causes
clotting, and produces
a fibrin shield that
inhibits phagocytosis.
The capsule inhibits
opsonization and
phagocytosis, as
well as protects from
C-prime-mediated
leukocyte destruction.
Protein A in the coat binds
immunoglobulin FC receptors
and inhibits opsonization,
phagocytosis, and is
also a leukocyte chemoattractant
and anticomplement.
catalase prevents oxidative
killing by immune cells
by degrading hydrogen
peroxide there are also other
enzymes that the bacteria
produces in order to break
down tissue to provide
metabolites for its growth most
staphylococcus aureus just
about a hundred percent
produce a pound of penicillinase
that opens the beta
-lactam ring, thus inactivating
penicillin. And there are
also endotoxins and
exotoxins that Staphylococcus
aureus produces to produce
different types of disease.
Staphylococcus aureus
produces a varied bunch
of skin diseases,
beginning with simple
boils, which are medically
termed for uncles.
These are infected
hair follicles
through carbuncles, which
is a coalesced cluster
of for uncles, a picture
of which is shown here.
Impetigo.
This is a skin infection
that begins with a cut
scrape that opens the
skin barrier that allows
toxin-mediated keratin
separation and flaccid
blisters in the case of
Staphylococcus aureus,
impetigo.
Streptococcus also
causes impetigo,
but the blisters
are a bit different.
It can cause pyogenic
wound infection. Pyogenic
means that it causes
pus, and it also
causes scalded skin
syndrome in small children
this is a locally
spreading inflammation that
causes peeling of the
squamous epithelium the child
usually recovers there
is an associated fever an
important sign here is
the narkolsky sign if you
apply horizontal pressure
to the skin adjacent to a
healing squamous epithelium
that appears normal,
it will shear off the top
layers of the epidermis.
Staphylococcus aureus
causes a myriad
of other diseases,
including bloodstream
infection, sepsis,
septic shock,
acute endocarditis, pneumonia,
empyema, osteomyelitis,
and septic arthritis none
of which are the topic
of this lecture there is
a toxic shock syndrome
that staphylococcus
aureus produces because
of super antigen production
super antigens are
proteins that stimulate t
-cell proliferation cytokine
production endothelial
destruction and capillary
leak, resulting in shock
and multi-organ failure.
Mucucutaneous signs include
a strawberry tongue,
which is one of the
criteria for toxic shock
syndrome due to
Staphylococcus aureus, and the
picture here shows the
diffuse erythematous
rash that is also associated
with this syndrome.
so the other big group
of staphylococci are the
coagulase negative
staphylococci this is a large
group of staphylococci
many different species
they are again catalase
positive and novobiasin
sensitive and they do
not produce hemolysis on
blood agon plates The
most common species, the
Staphylococcus epidermidis,
as we mentioned before,
this can be an
opportunistic pathogen,
usually of implanted
prosthetic joints,
implanted prosthetic heart
valves, or intravenous
catheters due to the
slime layer that this
bacteria produces, that
harbors the bacteria from
the immune system, as well
as antibiotic therapy.
Another example of
a coagulase-negative
staphylococcus is
staphylococcus saprophyticus,
which causes UTI in
******** active women.
turn now to the streptococci
these are again gram
positive they're non-motile
as opposed to clusters these
are in pairs and chains
and they are 0.5 to 1.2
micrometers in diameter. They
are catalase negative, as
opposed to streptococci,
which were catalase positive.
They're facultative anaerobes,
but they can really,
depending on the species,
range from strict anaerobes to
even capnophilic organisms,
which use CO2 for growth.
virulence factors include
the polysaccharide capsule
which is antiphagocytic um
the capsule is primarily
composed of higher hyaluronic
acid in group a streptococci
the m protein is present
in group a strep and causes
antiphagocytosis and can
also act as a super antigen
toxins include pyrogenic
toxins which cause fever
and erythrogenic toxins which
causes the rash of scarlet
fever the enzyme streptolysin
o is a enzyme that
causes hemolysis of red blood
cells and is responsible
for the hemolysis that is
shown on blood auger plates
so a mucous membrane
infection that is very
common is exudative
pharyngitis exudative means
that there is an exudate
in the posterior pharynx
that we can visualize
this is usually caused
by group a streptococci
patients present with
sore throat fever if
they're very young they may
may be febrile and cranky
the diagnosis is made by
visualization of the
pharyngeal exudate a swab that
is then used for a rapid
antigen test the answer to
that comes back in about
a few minutes and if it is
negative and it is felt
strongly that the person
has group A strep pharyngitis
a culture can be done.
Antistreptolysin O
antibodies are tested
from the blood and
are usually used to
assess a patient for
post-streptococcal
sequelae. We'll talk about
those on another slide.
First-line treatment of
exudative pharyngitis is
penicillin, although inloxacillin
and cephalexin can also
be used. And for those with
anaphylaxis to penicillin,
the options are clindamycin
and clarithromycin.
Let's talk about some
streptococcal skin diseases.
Empetigo is similar
to staphylococcal
empetigo, but the bole
tend to be more tense,
and there may be
some gold crusting.
Scarlet fever is a condition
of high fever, sore
throat, and a characteristic
sandpaper rash.
We've talked about the
erythrogenic toxin, but that
gene is actually encoded by
a lysogenic bacteriophage.
Erysipelas is a very
acute, rapidly progressing
superficial skin
infection that requires
immediate treatment with
antibiotic therapy. Patients
present with a bright
red, warm, tender, and
sharply demarcated black
with raised borders.
Cellulitis is also a
medical emergency. It
is a rapidly spreading,
very painful erythematous
skin and subcutaneous
tissue infection
that may result in
bloodstream infection
and or endocarditis if
not treated properly.
Another medical
emergency is necrotizing
fasciitis. This is
a rapidly advancing
erythematous warm
bolus condition.
You may feel crepitous when
you palpate the affected areas.
Crepitous reflects
gas in the tissues and
there is a dusky skin
discoloration. The
patients complain of
intensely painful skin that
is out of proportion
with the appearance.
There may be fever,
tachycardia, and signs
of sepsis, and patients
may eventually have septic
shock. These patients
require emergent surgical
debridement to remove the
tissue, and often they
need multiple surgeries.
Necrotizing fasciitis carries
a high mortality rate.
And lastly, toxic shock
syndrome is not really a
streptococcal skin disease,
although there is an associated
rash. um that the syndrome
is similar to staphylococcal
toxic shock syndrome with
some notable exceptions
non-skin and mucous
membrane diseases caused
by streptococci include
pneumonia I'm sorry
pneumonia which is
usually streptococcus
pneumonia um meningitis
um and the post
streptococcal sequelae of
group A strep infection,
usually pharyngitis
or scarlet fever.
These include
rheumatic fever, which
can cause cardiac
valve abnormalities.
This occurs after
group A streptococcal
pharyngitis or scarlet fever,
or post-treptococcal
acute glomerulonephritis,
which occurs after group
A strep pharyngitis.
In reality, we give
antibiotics to patients with
group A streptococcal
pharyngitis to prevent these
sequelae antibiotic
therapy for the pharyngitis
itself really has minimal
effect on the pharyngitis.
Other clinically important
streptococci include
streptococcus agalactiae.
This causes neonatal
bloodstream infection and
meningitis, as well as
postpartum sepsis, as it
colonizes the birth canal.
Streptococcus pneumoniae
is the most common
cause of community
-acquired pneumonia
and community-acquired
bacterial meningitis.
It also causes
sinusitis, otitis media,
bloodstream infection, and
sepsis. And the viridam
streptococci are the streptococci
that colonize the teeth
and gingiva, and these are
causes of endocarditis.
Pseudomonas aeruginosa
is not considered a skin
colonizer, but as we
said before, it can be
found transiently on
the skin in moist areas.
This is a gram-negative
motile oxidase positive
and non-lactose fermenting
gram-negative rod.
It causes or grows as
colorless colonies on McConkie
agar. It's ubiquitous
in moist environments.
The cell wall lipopolysaccharide
acts as an endotoxin
that causes the symptoms
of sepsis, and the
exotoxin A and isoenzyme S
inhibit protein synthesis.
Pseudomonas aeruginosa causes
infections in burns,
surgical wounds,
the lungs in patients with
cystic fibrosis, and causes
a characteristic ulcerative
lesion in patients
with neutropenia, especially
after chemotherapy called
ecthyma gangrenosum that
is pictured in this slide.
Proprietobacterium
acnes is the cause
of acne in young
adults. These are
gram-positive,
small, arrow-tolerant
rods that colonize the skin
conjunctiva, external
ear and pharynx.
uh they combine with
sebum to stimulate post
-inflammatory responses causing
the tissue damage of acne
a virulent pathogen
that is also a
colonizer of the upper
respiratory tract
is actinomyces israelii this
is a gram positive elongated
rod that can combine to
form filamentous long forms
they cause infections that
are associated with sulfur
granules in tissue example
of which is shown at the
bottom right they also cause
granulomatous sinusitis
a condition of lumpy jaw when
the oropharynx is involved
and pelvic and uterine
abscesses so mycobacterium
ulcerans is the cause of the
beruli ulcer this is an acid
fast bacillus that is
related to mycobacterium
tuberculosis these ulcers
occur in tropical africa and in
asia that are associated
with the aquatic environments
uh treatment is multiple
anti-mycobacterial
antibiotics the
prognosis is usually good
although the ulcers
can be quite chronic to
be clear mycobacterium
ulcerans is not a
colonizer for the skin
but strictly a pathogen
the illness we'll mention
in this lecture is
parvovirus b19 this causes
a characteristic slapped
cheek rash on the cheeks
of infected persons
parvovirus is a non
-enveloped icosahedral
single-stranded linear
dna virus the illness it
causes is erythema
infectiosum or fifth disease.
Fifth comes from the fifth
rash and fever illness
in children after measles,
scarlet fever, rubella,
Duke's disease. I'm
sorry, and Duke's disease.
Roseola is the sixth disease.
Adults can also get
it, but it is most
common in kids from
five to 15 years old.
The kids have
fatigue, headache,
the ache, fever,
usually 99 to 101,
37 to 38.5 centigrade,
runny nose and sore throat.
About 20% of those
infected are asymptomatic.
This is a self-limited
illness and there are
no sequelae in those
who are incompetent.
Thank you so much for reviewing
this lecture and good luck.
In summary, the normal flora
of the skin is predominantly
gram-positive staphylococci
and streptococci.
The skin flora and
pathogens cause various
infections of the
skin as well as toxin
mediated illnesses and
biochemical tests can
help identify pathogens
to direct therapy.
Please do give us feedback
on our lectures. I've
included a QR code
here. We really do value
your opinion to make
these lectures better.
Thanks so much and have
a great rest of your day.